cinema snob hell you doing here
Christ I need your help with something
me you need my help the great and
cynical cinema snob actually needs my
help
not really I'm just following the orders
you have in your script okay what do you
need it's this damn sharknado movie
sharknado yeah everybody's been talking
about it since they announced its
premiere on sci-fi especially with its
sequel coming out it's all over Twitter
Facebook hell there's even cosplays of
it at conventions it's like this
underground phenomenon okay what about
well obviously there's only one reason
that a piece of shit like this would
become such a big hit the magical star
power of Jon heard the name and my
thought is if I could come up with a
name that combines just as much epic
testosterone-filled bullshit then I
could make a bundle too the only problem
is is I haven't found the right combo
yet well what do you got let's see tanka
soros Chainsaw quake and transformers
zombies hmm that's not bad but
everybody's combining two things if you
really want push it to the next level
that you do three like werewolf
lightning ninjas hmm cannibal spider
Nazis nuclear Amish Holocaust cancer
beating Robo snakes gun testicle vampire
it's a chocolate Cthulhu Christmas wait
a minute this can't be the only reason
this movie is a hit there has to be
something outside of the name that
actually draws people to it I'd like to
see you find it well while we take a
look why don't we see why the people the
Internet are blown away by sharknado
what do you say Godzilla
vampire BOTS that's a sharknado so the
movie doesn't waste any time giving us
what we want as tons of sharks are seen
swimming away from this
dorm of the century don't you feel so
safe knowing that the coast always has
millions of sharks at one location at
any time maybe they're on the way to buy
Grand Theft Auto five we come across a
boat of fitters who are skinning the
most realistic sharks you'll see in this
movie as the captain of the boat gives
his financier a bowl of fuck you soup
that's good
not great I can't believe he doesn't
love my grandma's good but not great
soup my associates and I are willing to
negotiate a reasonable price s a hundred
thousand 1 million for the entire take
or my accent will get sillier help that
they're called waves they do not
think of it as a wicker car month
Antonio Ben Barris mint has postponed
his negotiations as he's being attacked
by the great comeuppance storm of 2013
oh come on pac-man doesn't eat people
that fast
and that's the last you'll see of the
sharknado for another hour
what yeah sharknado ironically has very
little sharknado in it well then why the
hell am i watching it oh don't worry
it's followed by the second most epic
thing you can imagine yeah what's that
Tara Reid's credit we see the leftover
beef footage from piranha 3d as the
local Beach is preparing for hurricane
plot point to arrive I've still got some
illusion what did I tell you we can
touch everything this far except for me
hey this is Nova a waitress who
apparently got head-butted by a Klingon
and this is George played by John heard
or rather the leftover audio of Krusty's
belches hey I'm not judging you darlin
dear to angle him up so he gives them a
look and you give them enough that I'm
not gonna have any place to drink oh
never get my aim back but sure enough
sharks start attacking in water much too
shallow for them to swim in and start
munching people up
- what's with the random pushing guy off
stairs thing maybe he was a shark spy
who accidentally buried my wake in the
sound and nobody thinks it's funny what
were you thinking you could have been
killed
I'm fine Nova runs into her friends Finn
and Baz who suffered a shark gnawing on
his leg for half a minute and yet his
wound looks like a ketchup packet got
burst by a rake sharks don't like
Vegemite it's smell funny
gonna be okay is she gonna be okay did
they just miss the guy who was bit by a
fucking shark
well medical emergencies are based on
how good the victims look in a bikini
fin and Baz are sharing their story when
Nova seems to overstep her boundaries a
bit what's happening okay hey be doing
what do you think you're to work for me
no I'm your boss so go get back to work
daddy issues hey I'm not judging you
darlin
I have daddy issues do you know you
think John heard was actually cast for
this movie or did they just happen to
come across him at the bar and they just
put him in hell I just assumed he came
along with any b-movie production so
what can I get with the gold B movie
package well you get the special effects
team would it go shark a guaranteed
sequel no matter how bad it is and for
no additional charge I'll throw in John
Hurt and what about the silver package
well you get the leftover CG effects
from reboot and directed evening release
and the cameo by Billy Zane hmm and what
about the bronze package Gary Busey oh
I'll take the gold package Jack so much
choice but an upcoming hurricane that
FEMA declares a category fuck gets been
concerned about his ex wife played by
Tara Reid april's Finn yeah man I know
your voice what do you want look I'm
just calling to make sure when did you
go back to using Wexler again yeah
that's my name look Finn I'm really busy
I'm busy walking past pictures of myself
and getting ready to go to Newfoundland
unless this is about a people's birthday
I'm not interested hurricane David is
poised to be the first hurricane at the
state of California widespread flooding
is expected at
experts are saying global warming is the
reason for this unprecedented event like
sharks on the other hand is due to
shitty writing
now that's what I like to call a dead
ball shot seeing how none of the Sharks
are adhering to the no shirt no service
sign they figure this is bad for
business and try to head out what is
this when Disney Animation attacks I'm
just trying to figure out why it's
cloudy and storming and half the shots
and then sunny and pleasant and the
other half
well you just went is the most
embarrassing moment of your life for the
chick of the shark pick one
oh yeah how would you like to be in a
movie called sharknado and it's the
fucking ferris wheel that kills you off
at the very least don't call you
ferris-wheel NATO
so seeing how today's now a day off they
decide to go check on Finn's ex-wife and
kid really worried about Claudia naval I
got a check on this Claudia his daughter
even ex-wife Anna donor as your employee
whom you had no romantic obligations to
I am very disturbed by his I want to go
with you but even the streets are no
longer safe as the water continues to
rise short street hey ho ho hold up with
the guns you don't need more blood in
the water yeah but shark comes up to you
planning to eat your guts out just say
you're gonna tell on his parents but too
many hit and swims start to take place
as our heroes try to get out and help
some of the people everyone
this looks like a job for my fighting
stool
I did a zoo a motherfucker joke the last
review that should tide you over but
alas the rest of our movie must go
unheard
tell Tom Hanks I said I don't get it
we didn't even get to make a whole alone
joke
our heroes press on and make it to
Tara's house and force their way in
I told you not to come away take your
notes different friend a bad thief by
the way I'm not stripper
they of course come across her jackass
boyfriend and her kind of Jackass
daughter I'm not going anywhere with you
just leave I did come here doggie okay
I'm here to get you what is all the
ruckus Oh
Shepherd I was off to play the villain
in Titanic - Finley April is mine excuse
me my girlfriend is not your
responsibility
Khan don't be rude yeah why can't you be
more like me trying to force them out of
a house there are sharks flooding the
streets
and now there's one something in your
book are you kidding sharks in the swing
pool is in pop no the Shepards really
gonna hit the fan
okay when the effects in this movie are
less impressive than the shark hand
puppet in third Rock from the Sun even
though someone needs a bigger budget had
to go to bed nice to get mad knots in
flight school there thought it was a
vacationing at Tampa with his buddies
who's mad my brother you have a son too
okay are we not in a relationship or
really not at a relationship
whoo well thank God I have sharknado
insurance they decide to make their way
to where his son is but of course more
trouble comes along we have to go get
that don't you see that there could be
kids in there there's no one in there
and your kid is right here we have to
get her somewhere safe this is so
typical of you Finn you care more about
other people than you do your own family
you know Tara I'm aware you're in a
movie called sharknado and you're not
gonna use your a material but can you at
the very least muster up a d-minus
performance no Tara I know that you're
trying to convey actual human emotion
but I swear to Christ if you don't get
this right I am going to replace you
with a lamp I understand just try to
convince me that you're not an alien we
can get through this and call it a night
okay got it
let me call my acting coach to help me
out whatever you need
commander the humans are on to me they
do not believe I am one of them do not
belittle time obviously consumer
navigates you're sitting there because
nearly at an end if they start to
suspect anything
true a strong emphasis to a body part
you have not drawn emphasis Korea how
you're running out of those but I will
do my best
all right you ready Terra yes
action Oh No a sharknado cards
well she's awful but she's got a damn
good back of the neck on with the next
scene
you
kerubim idiots come across another group
of idiots and decide it's best to help
them out
waters rising I'm gonna go up to the
bridge and rappel now you know I had to
side with fin here I mean what is he
supposed to do let all the children and
the bus be eaten alive by sharks and or
drowned to death maybe just when the
kids think there was finally a reason to
climb that damn rope in gym class it
looks like Hollywood itself is trying to
stop this movie
stop lingering on me Tamra don't you
know that means I'm gonna die you okay
my mom always told me Hollywood would
kill me but I always thought the part
about her say the side or not the
metaphor was especially confusing until
now the hurricane continues to fling
sharks across Hollywood sharks across
Hollywood that's not bad
write that one down and sure enough our
heroes fall victim to their flying ways
candygram
asshole Jesus how hungry are these
things it all shows I've seen about
sharks I've never seen one that said
they just constantly want to eat
everything put in front of them like
Cookie Monster all I did was confuse you
for seal may I smell gas
not you too come on guy mother gas leak
occurs inside their car and you know
what that means they need more gas nope
it just blows up we don't even see the
spark that sets it off it just randomly
blows up cool I forgot in crappy movies
gasoline is the nitroglycerin of
sensitive liquids
plus they need a new car and thankfully
a lot of famous studio cars is right
across the way so what famous vehicle do
they end up driving
this piece of shit that wasn't at
anything oh come on you have that set up
and you don't even take advantage of it
how cool would it be if they were
driving around in ecto-1
or the Batmobile or the shit on Johnny
Yong Bosch van hell this movie would
have been a fuck ton better if they got
to ride around in the Knight Rider car
oh my god how amazing would it be if
they rode in KITT from Knight Rider kid
we need your logic and effective
reasoning to help us out of course what
seems to be the problem there's a
sharknado chasing us no really what
seems to be the problem I told you
there's a sharknado I'm being serious
what is it it really is a short NATO
you're not going to tell me are you no
seriously without any hint of sarcasm
there is a tornado filled with sharks
and it's trying to kill us you know if
you guys aren't going to take this
seriously I'm just going to shut off
they make it to the location of Finn's
son but sadly it doesn't take much time
for our unnatural disaster to catch up
with them
was that the wind that took her out or a
Photoshop arrow the team's decided that
this has gone far enough
ironic because the sharknado has
literally just arrived so they try to
figure out a way to stop it
bombs bombs instead of letting live
sharks rain down on people we're gonna
get in that chopper and throw bombs into
the tornadoes wait a minute are they
literally talking about blowing up the
sharknado your son wants to go into a
helicopter and drop a bomb into the
tornado blasting those bastards to bits
yeah I say we take a baseball bat and
break that sharknadoes knees worked in
Jaws five didn't it
but how is that gonna stop a tornado
tornadoes happen when cold and warm air
meet now if you drop a bomb head right
in the middle of it you just might
equalize it you do know that the science
you've been listening to in Dexter's Lab
is not real science don't you Feeny I'm
surprised how little you know about
sharknado side almost surprisingly this
movie does attempt to throw in some
character development seeds or at least
that's what I think they're calling
these moments look what are you and Mom
doing guys could barely stand to be in a
room together for five minutes and now
what cuz you're saving Matt you guys are
best friends again
he is my son I'm your daughter you guys
are always there for him and you're
never there for me you don't think I
tried
not hard enough
I came for you first try to remember
the important thing is I like one of you
more than the other and admitting that
makes me a better parent who I've always
had a thing for french fries stuck on a
woman's legs I don't like to talk about
it oh well the pains too deep for you I
won no way do any coaxing whatsoever 'is
that my grandparents okay when I was
seven my grandpa took me fishing on one
of those DHR tour deals with his friends
suddenly all these sharks just started
swarming and and then they tried to
protect me but by morning they were all
gone you know do we really need a reason
to hate sharks in this movie I mean
they're giant killing machines who eat
people I don't think we especially need
to make this personal six people went
into the water you know one little girl
Kimmy and that's how I found out there
was no shark Santa Claus they took my
grandfather so I really hate sharks
now I really hate sharks - thanks for
that ingenious insight has it falling
from the sky eating people wasn't enough
well now they've attacked your dad's
kinda sorta but not really girlfriend
yeah is that Kyle like say you hate
Osama bin Laden after 9/11 but then
after you found out he didn't feed his
cat oh now I really hate him so the
quest is on - flying to the sharknados
there being three now because hey one
wasn't enough to bring people in and
just like they said before they looked
up blow it up
holy Sh you can pick down and fly on
Mars with that firepower
okay I'm not gonna act like I'm a
sharknado expert and I prayed a Lord God
that there's no such thing as a
sharknado expert but I'm gonna call
bullshit on the scientific data that
concludes you can fucking blow up wind
yeah I don't know I think even
Mythbusters would have a hard time
proving this one boy oh boy do we have a
myth for you where do you get a load of
this one we're gonna see if we can blow
up a tornado but filled with sharks
eight sharknado if you will
I'm Way too silver for this so why don't
I take a shot when we cut to a random
hot chick and her team
well whatever we're working on is never
as impressive as what you're working on
so let's get back to you that's better
so Jamie what do we learn today that if
two people can survive a tornado strap
through a drainage pipe of leather belts
anything is possible
so once again this hour of your life was
a waste of time why aren't you watching
storage wars Hey
so just as the first sharknado is blown
apart sharks start landing everywhere
resulting in probably the silliest thing
you're gonna see all week
whoa let's see that again on the
stupidly awesomely stupid ham and to
think some more out there there's a
person reading but a fucking loser they
take out the second one as well
resulting in the Sharks landing at the
old folks home
they're falling in a chlorine billed
pool this will probably take care of
itself
no the Sharks were the only ones to
visit us in years
hey Jamie a lot of people been wondering
is it possible to set water on fire
who the hell is wondering that let's
check you with a random hot chick um I
have a pH do you know whatever just say
some puns ah now we're really in hot
water I'm gonna go kill myself and my
trailer they arrived at the last one and
get ready to toss in the final bomb say
what is the inside of a sharknado look
like anyway
please stand up there it's my son you
must be so proud
honestly I went for my daughter first
but a shark latches itself onto the
helicopter and get a load of this not
even in the best played game of Tetris
two things fall back perfectly into
place
you look even the Sun when shouting no
he's kind of laughing a bit funny even
you can't laugh at the little things so
fin finishes the job by driving the last
bomb into it
this results in one last shark coming
down towards him
logic of itchy-scratchy cartoons don't
fail me now
what to the bar play look at what else I
found in here Jimmy Hoffa Amelia Earhart
am I missing let's suck whose shark has
everything really hate sharks
so the sharknadoes are destroyed these
two are back together for no reason and
the world lives happily ever after the
stupidest thing they've ever seen in
their entire lives
that's a whole lot of boobs guys do we
even need to sum up this movie if you're
even remotely interested in seeing a
film with a title as stupid as this
you're pretty much gonna get what you
expect it's lame it's crazy it's
completely over the top what else can
you say it's called sharknado so with
that said cinema snob do you really
think the success of this movie came
purely just from the title alone Grim
Reaper motorcycle man slaughtered 9,000
grand theft wizards ex cannibal
Confederates vs. Amazon girls a good way
with
beyond cannibal Confederate versus
Amazon girls and koko popular meme
versus other popular me Bruce Campbell
versus himself Oh Hayley you're not
gonna believe this
according to my shitty movie alert hey
that's a good at isn't it I really
enjoyed sci-fi is releasing all the
titles that we just named here great
well how so we gonna exploit our extreme
marketing crappy ideas hi they fired me
for Mythbusters do you guys need any
help around here blueberry tea very
yummy
kitten rainbows unicorns Sparkle poofy
muffin Easy Bake Oven words salad cuddly
castle of cheerleading cannibals wait
doesn't go against the whole cutie
feminine thing well that's the great
thing about extreme marketing for the
female demographic is that so many
options have over them like you see dark
innocent edgy stay-at-home mother nero
derma bio surgeon or all of the above
Wow so what about extreme marketing for
the male demographic oh we got a lot of
stuff huh we can be manly that's about
it yeah well let's just keep working on
exploiting this one oh yeah
iron twinkle robo princess mega Saga 2 -
terror - 2 - Boogaloo powerpuffs Suicide
Girls based on the novel by Sapphire
glitter death makeover
no blood petunia of polka dot hell's
black and white the final days of
rainbow bright pink thunder Sofia
Coppola and Robert Rodriguez present big
fun with special guest director Quentin
Tarantino
oh my Vidal Sassoon's choice Turkish
Pippi Longstocking bridezilla vs.
Godzilla on ice
there's potential
Oh Shepherd